I didn't know this but someone's told me
today that you get very intense stage
fright when you come out and do things
that's not something you have right now
right yeah I have it's horrible you have
it right now yes and a purposeful you
didn't drink so it's really bad okay
all right I purposely didn't drink like
like drinking is a natural state yeah
yeah okay well people don't also know
that we tape a little early this is not
really 11 o'clock at night this is this
is 4:20 in the afternoon no but for you
to like say hey it's mid-afternoon and
I'm not drinking that's sad do you
really how bad is your stage fright its
I was just thinking cuz I knew we were
gonna talk about this what is it that's
so horrible and it's sort of two things
one I think it's that I'm still like oh
my god I'm on a talk show talk show
right and you're in my living room and
then here I am and it's just weird yeah
but I really do come into your living
room you gotta close the window yeah I'm
you know I've been attracted to you for
a long time and
I know where you live know what what's
what's strange is I can kind of relate
to because there's a lot of stuff that
you do where you're behind a camera
you're on a set it's like a closed set
it's a closed situation here there's
people is that that what that's not the
only thing it's also that you're just so
famous and you're famous and it's just
it's just weird I still feel like a
weird sense of awe and then what happens
is I start blacking out like right now
and I can hear my voice and I'm like am
i speaking English yeah you're doing fun
you're doing fine right now but I'm just
curious when you get those kind of
panicky feelings what's the compulsion
is the compulsion to like leave is the
compulsion to hide what's the what does
it blackout and then and then and and
but it's usually just this horrible
anticipation before I come out that I'm
going to go onstage and just say
something horrible like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well see you didn't and and and you're
fine
and that is my little sandy we're not
moving past that we're not moving past
that I look at you have you were afraid
that you would say that right and so you
to conquer fear you said it it's my
mom's a shrink it's called counter
phobia and it's when you do the thing
that you're so wildly trying to repress
your mother I have to say Amanda you
given me two right now and I prefer the
first one I don't know if this is like
ice cream at a parlor but I I want
number one okay what God so so that's
part of it and then it's just even if
it's if it's and then if it's even if
it's with you it's like that if it's if
it's it's like oh [ __ ] I'm tanking and
then I know you're doing great people
are gonna talk about this segment let me
hold you
your hands are cold by the way your
hands are very cold yeah
cold hands cold heart yeah it's like one
time I was with the amazing an Meera
who's wonderful actress and comic and
and I was telling her about my stage
fright this was years ago
you think I'd have moved in the right
direction by now but and she just leaned
over and said she's a big smoker she
said as soon as you want to be good and
you did what oh really as soon as you
want to be good you're dead so if I come
out here and I don't mind tanking I'm
not gonna be nervous right but if I come
out here and I'm I'm like oh my god it's
Conan oh my god it's Conan oh my god oh
my god I better be funny I better be
right something then right then it's
time to say suck my can then
everything's okay everything's
we're okay now I know what to do if ever
I'm stuck in a moment interviewing
someone for super faintness they can
always like just blurt that out okay
well does that never happen to you
talking to someone like one time I had
to speak to Brad Pitt for like two
minutes and and the things that were
going through my brain it was like
airplanes at the beach when they have
those tag things I was like no that's
inappropriate no inappropriate no I mean
so I think I probably just sat there
just just frozen like right like a I'm
not gonna say like a just yeah it for
you for you to edit yourself at this
point means what you were about to say
is so horrible that I don't want you to
say it but oh my god you for the things
you've said for you to stop yourself
there that's really incredible and now I
know you really want to say it and I'm
not gonna let you okay because it'll end
your career
okay sure I'm sure it's that bad yeah
yeah like a career just as simple so
what I'm saying is II to have a career
ender so what I'm it's interesting what
I'm noticing is a pattern me Brad Pitt
you're talking to these guys
here
you
you